We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I'm playing this voicemail for two reasons.
Number one, as I mentioned earlier in the
show, all of our protest and George Floyd
coverage is being de monetized on YouTube
and Facebook.
So the fact that someone called in and actually
praised our coverage really means a lot.
And number two, it has been really heartwarming
to see the number of people reaching out to
me and saying, David, I really appreciate
your coverage of the protest.
You're not creating these false black white
hot takes.
You're actually dealing with the complex nature
of what's going on.
Here's one voicemail caller who made a similar
point.
Daisy.
David, one of the reasons why I'm happy to
be a subscriber of yours is that you're probably
the best progressive commentator out there.
You're not delusional.
You're not crazy.
And you honestly try to report the news from
an honest and fact based perspective.
Thanks for covering the George Ford story
very well and pointing out that this is a
story of many stories and not just one thing
that you need to focus on.
There's so many problems in this country that
this is revealing.
Thanks for being a good reporter.
I so appreciate that.
And thanks to everybody who has been writing
in about.
About our coverage.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Don't miss it.
Get a membership at join Pacman dot com to
get instant access to the bonus show.
I will see you then.